we're in Philadelphia and I wanted to
buy a battle-axe sure I'm sorry a
battle-axe battle-ax
a double-headed battle-ax don't act like
I'm an astronaut I you know I stand a
battle-axe
you know what up in medieval weapon next
thing we know he's gonna be going what's
a mace what else he had cut a
cheesesteak wait so he went to this
place called Asian treasures and we went
in and this Asian woman was trying to I
guess I look like a guy who would buy a
sword because she started telling me
these swords are very good price being a
price and she kept showing and I was
like yeah I know and she's like this
battle axe you like the battle axe
they're good price good price battle axe
hundred dollars good price
and I was like compared to what yeah
yeah I wasn't price checking on Amazon
for I keep like 100 bucks per okay I
like that it's got a school in the
middle but so I I had asked and I said
will you we let me buy this battle axe
if she said no of course not you want to
bring a battle axe on a moving bus
you're gonna cut yourself
I said please please please can I please
we have a battle axe for the bus it'll
be our bus every time we get out of new
city I'll just
yeah that's incredible we'd have these
little co-ed has these protectors on it
yeah and so Kate said no you're gonna
you're gonna cut yourself if you buy
battle ax and I said wait what what if I
don't what if I don't take these off
then it's that it won't be dangerous she
said all right you promise to superglue
them and I said swear guys guess what I
didn't do nope I didn't superglue and I
was on the bus practicing my moves can I
go over here sure sure just oh I was
practicing my moves and I taken these
off cuz they know all right sure
yeah you don't want a baby proofed
battle-ax oh do not yeah sorry
in my room I'm sorry I know you redeemed
yourself yeah so I cut myself and Kate
came in of course right in that moment
and she said what did you do and I was
like nothing it's not yourself by hand
and it was just bleeding you know it's a
battle-axe oh it's just bleeding paper
cut it's a battle ax cut yeah and she
just cut yourself with the battle ax I
went and so she took it from me and she
superglued these on right right and we
were walking in the mall of America
around the Mall of America we were
partying in the bus and I saw it you
know it ended and then we went we went
we tried to walk around the mall of
America it's a very large mall because
that's mall in the world isn't it yeah
it took 40 minutes for us to get to a
Nordstrom's that I had seen from a
distance I thought I thought we were
near a Baby Gap turns out we were so far
away there's actually a regular gap yeah
okay so we're walking and I'm a real
gentleman and it was very very it was uh
it was very cold outside and Kate was
wearing you know sleeveless she was she
was wearing spaghetti straps yeah middle
of all you know it's so cold outside I
mean why did these women wear the
Mamamia why I wouldn't forget strives
yeah yeah and I I think the character by
the way so I I said do you want my shirt
cuz I was wearing a shirt and she no no
no and then I did it so I hear also he
took you took your shirt off I took my
shirt off and I gave it to her really
don't have to Wow
[Applause]
so so we're walking and you took your
shirt off oh we can test it now and put
it around her
I knew it I'm your wife now in this
story you're my wife okay so I sort of
put it around earlier yeah okay good and
then we're walking so I'm shirtless and
I have a battle-axe and I say I say you
know it would be so funny look at us
walking if he's so insane if somebody
saw us and then what would and it was
the police the police and we turn and
there's this cop and he goes surf with
the battle-ax down and step towards the
vehicle and that's real he said battle I
know it's been evil weaponry yeah so I
so I you know I put the battle ax down
because I'm not afraid of anything and I
walked over to him and he's like I need
to see some ID what's what's going on
with this girl here I was like that's my
wife he's like miss can you come over
here then I realized that would be the
strangest hostage situation ever so they
took her IDs and he ran them ostensibly
four previous medieval weaponry to
ensure you're caught with a lance in
Lansing Michigan that's ironic well cut
that out actually leave it and I like
you when I bomb and
[Applause]
and so and I want to tell you that when
after I cut myself you know and she said
give me the battle ax I'm gonna
superglue these things on I had to you
know you cave it up like that I gave it
to her so this coffee runs the IDS then
he comes back he goes so this is in fact
your husband miss and she said yes I
started laughing out loud
because then he said why are you
laughing I said do you realize what you
just said you're like so this was that's
that this is the decision you made this
is it for all time so he put the
Belloc's in the back of the cop car and
he gave us a ride back to the Radisson
which is the definition of white
privilege and and so he got back and I
realized he's probably gonna confiscate
the battle-ax right but I run back to me
because I don't think we can let you
keep this I governor no but look do you
see on the sides here okay see right
here you can't hurt anything see so it's
a prop it's a prop for my show and he
goes okay he gave it to me which kudos
to the Minnesota Police Department that
that happened I think that's really cool
so they gave it back to me and I run
into the hotel because kids are in there
and go Kate Kate look look look look and
she goes do they let you keep the battle
ox I said yeah and she goes why
[Applause]
you